wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he made a fortune in ukraine in china in
moscow that is simply various of the
places
oh man look at my life
[Music]
home and take a look at my life i'm a
lot like you
what should people know about hunter
biden that they don't know well i made a
lot of decisions that i probably
shouldn't have made probably smoke more
parmesan cheese than anyone
oh man take a look at my life
54 years of crack and [ __ ]
stumbling around the house cutting
business deals with you
i'm lost on the sauce
really dark my wires crossed
like when you get completely lost as you
walked
investigation on hunter biden the
president's son survived hunter biden
could face federal sex trafficking
charges for transporting prostitutes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just one look
[Music]
no one
votes or will vote for or against my dad
because of me do you still believe that
100
17
of biden voters said they would have
changed their vote or not voted had they
known about the hunter bite and laptop
story that lost look in your eyes
falling down your pants are crowned
spending days in such a haze and totally
confused
living life completely gassed look at
all the time that's passed
often i'll also fill my pants
my dad doesn't go after other people's
kids
[Music]
[Music]
just one look in our eyes the country
knows it's true
[Music]
oh man look at my life i'm a lot like
you
are
oh man look at my life i'm a lot like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um that's well it's not the sound of
monday because you had your kami holiday
yesterday i hope you all enjoyed it it's
a poor excuse for picking a man's pocket
every first monday of september it's yes
every first monday of september since
i'm the only one who seems to see that
take the day off uh by the way you can
it's parody week tomorrow we have uh we
have the pelosi song oh and then uh we
have on thursday we have the elon omar
song which is actually a parody of
taking back sunday and yes it is all
about uh her consummating with her
brother
you can go and download all these tracks
also like 25 other parody tracks you
guys have been asking for it spotify
apple android go subscribe to the show
and you can listen to all of them so and
take take them with you let's go take
them with you on the go it's portable uh
my question today before i get into
anything else is
is joe biden
the former vice president you see the
most divisive former vice president of
all time
a lot happened here uh since we didn't
have a show on friday thursday he gave
that speech
the hitler looking speech yeah looking
bad lighting hitler looking speech then
he walked it back of course
on saturday or was it yesterday i don't
know it's tough to keep track for days
but i think a lot of people have missed
something that i want to get into here
it's very different if you look at
donald trump for all of his flaws his
rhetoric was squarely aimed at the
elites in power the democrats
joseph robinette's biden
joseph robinette bidens
it's hard i have to get it all right
yes
um
red robin yum i don't know that's the
worst it's the most inaccurate slokan
ever but you remember it no one says yum
at red robin hunters use the onion ring
tower for many reasons yes exactly it's
like you know i just want a side of parm
just decide if that's the only thing
you're ordering it's not a side just a
mane of parm
uh so it's aimed squarely at you
joe biden has a problem with you the
voter the citizen not the people in
power that's unprecedented so we're
going to talk about that we're also
going to talk about the mass stabbing in
saskatchewan my homeland of canada 10
people this is not the first time this
has happened i don't know if you know
this violent crime occurs elsewhere uh
across the globe at much higher rates in
the united states and i'm really glad
that we have the uh the second amendment
so
move in that and more gerald a how are
you i am well sir good still pissed off
about monday
still pissed off i just don't you know
because i we don't as business owners we
don't get labor day off i love it i took
yesterday off i'll be honest
i didn't i thought about business if
that helps yeah yeah there you go it
doesn't no and then you know me loving
the fastest man on his feet the quickest
wit in the west and he will be with me
we're together uh september 17th smart
financial center sugar land in houston
how are you dave ahoy good ahoy yes good
we're gonna get you with the ahoys and
him with the sound board oh i know
that's all i got this is just gonna no
i'm good yourself i i'm i'm all right
i'm all right i i i hurt my back again
since i started barbecuing with fam did
you yeah i didn't barbecue oh i ain't no
barbecue you didn't barbecue i didn't
barbecue i i would have liked to but no
i did not
well this that's the end of that
conversation hey
uh announcements
you're like i would have loved me like
the lone native american with a piece of
trash
watching your neighbors yeah like
it's just a shrink wrap from a rib eye
that i didn't get all you have to do is
turn yours on
it's there uh announcements start we
have to kind of get through all of these
versus uh charleston west virginia on
october 8th that date has had to be
moved it's uh it's canceled here for
this uh this f fall the spring tour uh
we're going to move it to the it's fall
that's right i'm sorry what i meant to
say is it's canceled for the fall tour
we'll move it to spring because of a
personal scheduling conflict that i uh
family count i just couldn't get out of
so all your tickets will be refunded and
at least 20 of you actually know what 50
of you we are going to gerald's like 20
50 of you uh if you send your email to
tips at lightwithcredit.com and uh your
stub of the ticket that will be refunded
we will actually fly you out and pay for
the hotel and get you tickets to the
houston show yeah september 17th so make
plans tips at louderathcrider.com we
apologize we will reschedule in west
virginia all right
now that i'm done with all that uh first
have you seen this you've seen this clip
yet have you dave i have not i didn't
want to surprise myself once i read the
setup trust me it's worth it yes and you
have to watch until the end
or once
myself good things for those who wait
you never really realize how impressive
american cowboys are sorry extremists
who are a threat to democracy true true
until you see just how crappy the
cowboys of other countries truly are
here's what i mean
what a jeep
[Laughter]
it's over it's over he's in the clear on
the car right
[Laughter]
i can't ride
anything down
he had some scratches from the bull but
he died of a broken neck falling off the
rescue jeep
and now you're christopher reeve because
i believe i can fly oh well that's you
know the most dangerous part of bull uh
bull riding is the car yes oh i've
always said that the suv the reaction of
the guy in the video
i feel like rule number one is get on
but rule number two is probably hold on
to whatever it is yes exactly
stay on
just spiderman hands whatever you touch
grab just grab a hold of something
i don't even need to run away quickly in
the jeep just drive slowly away once the
bullet gonna do hit the car come on
bleeding take his life
what was he thinking he went out there
he didn't have like a lasso or a gun
like a hat he had nothing he was
complete what did he think he was going
to do
he didn't even have marlboros
he's a wreck
some chaps like put in an effort to do
something
police speak
if you're going to look like that well i
think all chaps are askless are they all
yeah it's an oxymoron i mean what chaps
have an ass then he wouldn't be choking
oh hi well he actually not the ones i
wear
just was diagnosed with monkey boxes yes
well that also brings us to uh i should
let you know i told you i would inform
you today uh was banned from twitter
suspended for 12 hours
i'll get to why so first off let me i'll
foreshadow here uh former vice president
joe biden has now requested another 47
billion dollars in emergency funds from
congress four oh good covid 22 billion
is still a thing ukraine 13 billion
natural disasters 6 billion and then
monkey pox vaccine distribute 4.5
billion
emergency funding now i can understand
if this was some kind of a virus or
disease you know what like you never saw
it coming yeah here's the thing
statistically a lot of people saw it
yeah we absolutely saw it coming
and we still sit and we still see it
spreading
like there's no doubt so this is these
are the new statistics all references
available at loudoutcredit.com uh this
disease is entirely preventable
how why i know you're saying hey yeah
steven dave gerald i trust you how uh
how can i prevent monkey pox mask
wearing
know about sex with dudes you're good
that's it that seems so 97.5 there's
another way
what's door number two i'm not a monk
i think door number two is the problem
97.5 percent of united states cases have
occurred between men who have sex with
men
uh plus one percent uh who identify as
bisexual so 98.5 percent well so that's
not everyone
who invents it they split out the one
percent
this might have been like the kids who
got it and the the bloodhound oh my gosh
that's true the one percent that was
molested or a dog science they don't
identify as men who have sex with men
though they have sex with men and are
men imagine being that parent bringing
in sorry the the two gay adoptive
parents bringing in that kid with monkey
pox to the doctor and like uh they're
sitting on his monkey box it's like oh
so it's uh
airborne it's not airborne uh maybe it
could have been air assault aerosol
maybe no is that no sir no oh well i
guess this is one of those your guess is
as good as mine i
no it's not a guess we need to call cps
where's dr house when you need him yeah
what's cps here for to give you an award
for being the greatest parent yes
exactly because we live in stupid times
exactly they're both covered with monkey
pots so 98.5
right occur between men who have sex
with men and i was suspended from
twitter
in related news uh last week for this
tweet
i said they refused to call monkey pox
uh a gay disease now
to be clear also this included context
at that point we had those numbers where
it came from uh i think was business
insider cnbc where they said hey it
seems that it's not just
uh it's not just being gay it's not just
gay men but it seems to travel
specifically through sexual contact
between two men so that context was also
provided on twitter and they still
suspended me
so i here's the thing after
thinking about what they'd done i'm back
on twitter right now by the way i would
uh
i actually want to take this moment to
apologize
for
my description of the monkey pox virus
it was
insensitive
it was ill-timed
and it was grossly inaccurate
the suspension has forced me to do some
self-reflection twitter i should be
thanking you i realize that i have a lot
of growing up to do
i owe the good people of twitter better
i owe myself better
and above all
i owe you better
so i'd like to take this opportunity to
correct my previous callous inaccurate
description of monkey pox and offer an
amended appropriate one in its place
monkey pox
according to leading scientists
epidemiologists and the overwhelming
data is not in fact a gay virus
as i previously stated in reality it is
a virus which merely affects
98.5
disproportionately of those who have
men who have sex with men
and men who have sex with men related
communities largely do this novel method
of transmission which
is both gross and hilarious
butt sex
okay about sex
i'm sorry
that's good
it's powerful
everyone feel better i do that was
beautiful thank you i do i'm not above
recognizing when i'm wrong and writing
them
well i just felt i felt good
like
yes
just like that's the problem
a minute a minute on the lips forever on
the monkey box hips
by the way it's a live show monday
through thursday at 10 a.m eastern
are we still on youtube glad we could
clear that yeah
i mean you didn't say anything that
wasn't scientifically accurate no no no
that's the problem again remember
scientific journals now have to get rid
of data that might be considered
offensive so this is a live show monday
through thursday 10 a.m eastern except
for comedy holidays like labor day you
can watch us on rumble you can listen to
the audio podcast where you can go
listen to all the parody tracks now too
you have that entire playlist and of
course mug club uh which uh you have a
full extra hour of show it's a hundred
percent longer every day uh and you can
just check here on youtube for as long
as we're here all right
here's something do i to hit this first
or get to i i guess i'll have to hit
this okay first so last week uh the ap
uh featured a story uh and by the way
people aren't having kids nearly as much
as they used to i'd love to hear from
you if you comment below um how old you
are and if you plan on having children
or if you do have children because it is
a problem
so ap featured talking about
ap featured a story of a 24 year old
texas woman named l johnson who decided
to have her tubes removed and there was
a whole piece right now showcasing many
different people actually one person
here in the office knew one of the girls
really yes personally
so
uh they were talking about why people
are not having children anymore you know
uh here at ap and a big part of it was
because of social conscientiousness you
know climate crisis or overpopulation so
johnson this one lady again her name is
uh l johnson
cited many reasons for tying her tubes
and
not wanting children including quote the
climate crisis
i don't think it's responsible to bring
children into this world she also said
there are already kids who need homes
i don't know what kind of world it's
going to be in 20 30 40 years so the
idea was a lot of people are not having
kids because they think the world is the
worst place and this is a real problem i
think the world is going to be a worse
place than it was for their parents this
is the first time where that's taken
place uh she also by the way johnson
cited the roe v wade of course decision
that it was sealed by roe v wade i was
thinking about getting my tubes tied and
then after roe v wade i absolutely had
to
one issue here uh johnson as a lesbian
so guess how i know you're mentally ill
without telling me you're mentally ill
because she didn't buy a turkey base
she's not a stand-in for don't breathe
my god
yes
and we didn't know you were a lesbian
without hair not at all so i am a
lesbian and because of robie story
i'm a lesbian and because of roe v wade
i'm going to have my tubes tied in order
not because i don't want to bring
children into this world
and
the ap just they heard her story and
they decided to put it in their little
mobile carousel like yeah this is this
is a perfect this won't make us look
silly it sounds perfect most of the
excuses you heard were people being
selfish oh it's too expensive i can't do
this one person one couple hmm making
164 000 a year just could not find the
resources to raise a child what it means
is they don't want resources going out
of their account for something else
the cost of boy haircuts that's true
five dollars not to mention the blue
dodge yeah it's interesting
i think you could get it done by melting
a freezie but that's not how it works no
that brings it piercing piercing pagoda
three times what they were in the night
exactly
i mean even even it's just a cubic
zarconium it doesn't matter no
it's a sacrifice a lesbian
because of roe v wade having her tubes
tied because she doesn't want to bring
children into this world because of
climate change and roe v wade and we're
we we are so far beyond the point of
finding company
it's a real story the references are
available you can go check it out this
is from a legitimate news outlet hey why
i got to take a pregnancy test i mean we
were motion muffs all night right
i've got to be pregnant right i mean
there's no way in god's green earth i
couldn't be pregnant right after a night
of lesbian sex i identify as pregnant
and i would like to identify as someone
who had an abortion you know you know
what
don't have kids you are 100 correct you
and people like please do not have kids
thank you surgery to prevent it yeah i
hope that your doctor tying your tubes
is a clown who specializes in balloon
nuts
it's just pretend
oh it's a slick do you want a
hysterectomy or do you want a
a sword yeah
he just hands you a crazy straw here
they are
his face painting you
does your friend want to be a tiger
right
but this brings us into by former vice
president biden you're the extremist
because you voted republican maga
republicans which by the way i mean 70
something million people who voted for
donald trump no this is not the
extremist why do you mistrust your
institutions like legacy media and
mainstream media well i don't know
because you ran a story about a woman
who felt the need to tie her tubes
because of roe v wade even though she's
a lesbian
could it be any more virtue signaling
could it be any more clear of an example
of political grandstanding and we're all
supposed to sit here and go oh yeah no
we don't want to be uh extremist you
know and say hey that's crazy
there's so many lesbians that saw that
we're probably like you didn't need to
do that yes yeah
no but i wanted to yeah right but you
didn't need to do that also guess why i
don't support socialized medicine
my tax dollars at work
[Music]
hi i'm here for the elective pointless
surgery oh great also do you know if
bass pro accepts ebt cards for plaid
shirts
sorry
i need a fishing license i'm just
kidding so she just need to look like i
fish she just shows up to eddie bauer
with an ice pack on her womb oh
rough day
[Laughter]
yes i'll take all the flannel should get
in her eddie bauer explorer
[Laughter]
all right so this brings us to ex again
the the exact uh
kind of i guess i would say this is a
crystallization of our time so we were
off on friday and biden gave a speech on
thursday and i'm actually glad that we
didn't do a show on friday because then
he changed what he said in a speech
retroactively he said no i didn't mean
what i actually said and people said but
you said it he said yeah i know
and i meant it but i didn't mean it and
let me just let me too i want to get to
a couple of points that i think other
people are missing because i know a lot
of you out there and i'd love for you to
comment below if it made you sick to
your stomach watching the speech and
before you hear or watch this segment
i'd like you to tell me why you think
that is because i think that i have a
hunch
first off when i saw this speech
i was asking myself okay why is he why
give this speech now i could understand
if he was trying to feather in the fact
that he hates you the voter republicans
right maga republicans as he calls them
if there was a speech because there was
a declaration of war or maybe after uh
something like a 911 or some kind of
hurricane katrina some kind of
harvey natural disaster where he needed
to address the nation and then said and
by the way we also have some bad actors
but none of that he decided to take the
podium
and give a speech
with the soul the express purpose of
targeting political opposition that has
never happened in my lifetime i don't
know if you can remember that ever i was
saying why is he given why he's given
this speech he's giving it just to say
people who voted for donald trump are a
threat to democracy and here's something
else that i think is very telling i
would encourage you to go and watch the
whole speech
donald trump
for all his faults i really don't
believe he reviled
biden voters democrat voters he had a
problem with the people in power and by
the way he did it with the elites in
power with republicans think about it
jeb bush people like marco rubio
he had a problem with the ruling class
he coined the term the swamp you may not
like it right because a lot of people on
the left said he's sowing mistrust in
the institutions but he never
called for targeting
or for marginalizing of biden voters for
the same reason that people hated donald
trump right his charlottesville speech
to give you an example after that and he
did the media did a hatchet job he said
i'm not talking about white supremacist
neo-nazis who should be condemned
totally but his famous quote he said
there were fine people on both sides
think about that for a second
what he was saying was hey there are
people who wanted these statues down and
there are people who want to keep these
statue statues up because even though
these figures are flawed they believe
it's a part of their history and there
were fine people on both sides in other
words he was saying that there were fine
people on the side of his political
opposition even though he didn't believe
in tearing down statues he was saying
there are people on both sides who have
legitimate points and they should be
able to have a discussion the same quote
which has been taken out of context for
which people blame donald trump is proof
positive that his disdain is not with
you
it's with the people who lie to you joe
biden's problem is with you so let's
show the first portion of his speech
where he condemned quote
maga republicans you everyone in this
room too much of what's happening in our
country today is not
normal no [ __ ] sherlock donald trump and
the migrant republicans
an extremism
that threatens the very foundations of
our republic
now i want to be very clear
very clear up front
not every republican not even the
majority republicans are maggie
republicans
not every republican embraces their
extreme ideology
i know
because i've been able to work with
these mainstream republicans that's also
a lie we'll get into that question zero
voted for his biggest political party
today is dominated driven and
intimidated
by donald trump and the migrant
republicans
and that is a threat to this country
okay first off
who again i want to i want to uh
contrast here you the voter
who out there if you're a republican
you're a conservative are you
intimidated by donald trump even people
if you're a never trumper you don't like
him are you intimidated by donald trump
well why are you now
right yeah that's what i don't
understand like you what what opposition
are you going against right now right
what are you doing now they have
everything your backdrop is lovely by
the way well exactly who was paid to
stage this event the optics were
actually they were so bad that cnn again
if you want to see the media running
interference cnn actively tried to
change the coloring you know from the
aggressive fascist blood red
to like a knight like a fuchsia
and you can see it and i want to show
you this you can watch it in real time
they said this looks bad this looks bad
this looks bad cnn was running
interference form and you can see the
colors of the flag change where they
become kind of a a move
right yeah do you have you want me to
run that clip yeah let's run this clip
uh oh wait hold on a second actually uh
yeah let's run yeah clip b
okay democracy endures only if
we the people respect the guard
of the republic
see the background look at the flag we
the people accept the results of free
and fair elections only if
we the people
and you can see it on the flag the red
stripes and the flags
they didn't change the lighting of our
differences cnn changed the color
democracy cannot survive
when one side believes there are only
two outcomes to an election
either they win
or they were cheated
and that's where the maga republicans
are today
yeah
and by the way he also went on just to
be clear as you see that background he
did go on this was disturbing to say
this
at least he didn't stumble on his words
no i gotta say
he was a better public speaker yes
for all his faults he didn't need a
teleprompter no i mean he really just
felt it think about this though what
he's saying is maga republicans that
means
74 million people that's my question
here who qualifies as maga
do we have that to ding the question no
that's okay
[Laughter]
um 74 million people who voted for
donald trump the most in history right
other than other than joe biden right
other than joe by the most in history up
until that point the second most in
history until then also it's like they
broke the record twice in this last
election it's like with an asterisk well
it's because joe biden really enthused
his base hmm
i think if he just turned off that last
a it would have helped right if it was
just make america great yes that's what
we should have gone with that's what i
just get mad again what do you mean
again well we mean that there was eight
years of obama now another four years of
former vice president biden and you know
what it's not great
you know who said that bill clinton said
that right america great again so yeah i
guess he's a fascist too so let's get
through this and and i think the reason
it rubs a lot of people the wrong way is
because you are the target there's a big
difference between joe biden being the
target and i mean this figuratively
between uh jeb bush being the target
between kamala harris being the target
the political target versus you the
voter the citizen donald trump didn't do
that do you think this is to stir up
stuff before uh november though to
really cause somebody to go off the
rails and then be like see they're
dangerous right oh that's what i think
well but look every single time that i
don't and
i don't think that it's crazy to think
that no no not at all and every single
year yeah i'm not saying it's a thought
every time it gets broad
they they start winning because people
are like oh i have to vote against
donald trump i have to vote against maga
republicans because they're this subset
of republicans that we have to go out
and defeat so every time he doesn't want
to talk about what he's done he doesn't
want to talk about his policies he just
gave a speech on who to hate right that
was it right now talk about what he's
done these policies are fantastic and
wonderful and might be overturned by the
supreme court who knows student loan
debt right right he's not going to talk
about that stuff he's going to talk
about this enemy that we all have to
kind of galvanize ourselves against
right that's his only the other yeah
it's the other it's the maga republic
and then he said well i'm talking about
maga republicans so that's 74 million
people who voted for donald trump and
it's hard for me to find these numbers
maybe you could send them in it would be
helpful i do know 45 million dollars
worth of maga hats the official mug hats
were sold in 2019 alone i believe that
it is the single uh best-selling piece
of political politically oriented
merchandise in american history
certainly more than biden harris or
build back better the point is this is a
lot of this includes a lot of americans
people who would wear that hat
yeah
and here's something else too that i
think rubbed people the wrong way and
some other media outlets may be missed
um
they always try and use the constitution
notice that the left when it's
convenient for them and of course no one
buys it and i mean democrats don't buy
it either republicans clearly don't
democrats don't how can i prove to you
that democrats only use the constitution
as a cudgel well here's why
and we're going to do a segment on the
midterms tomorrow how democrats have to
sort of fake like their centrist in
order to win and then govern far left
whereas republicans have to appeal to
their base right this is this is the
what they lament the base is too extreme
but at least republicans there their
feet are held to the fire look at how
republicans conservatives look at where
they are upset with joe biden and why is
it relates to the constitution for the
same reason that sometimes conservatives
were upset with donald trump they will
say hey he's trampling on our
constitutional rights what angers
republicans these extremists these
conservatives is your pissing on the
constitution the first amendment the
second amendment whereas the left
they say well when it's convenient look
at this constitution because you're
questioning the integrity of election
results which by the way joe biden did
kamala harris did elizabeth warren did
amy klobuchar did jimmy carter did
hillary clinton uh yeah bernie sanders
they all did yeah take your pick from
the democrat all of them did
but the difference here is um when it
comes to the constitution let's
disregard the voting issue they think
it's racist
look at the black lives matter demands
look at the demands of all these
activists look at the articles at
alternative press at uh at huffington
post it's well the constitution was
written by racist white guys so we now
have systemic discrimination because of
the constitution they don't like the
constitution they want to do away with
it when convenient the republican the
maga the extremist voter base they are
only extreme
in that they expect you and they want
you to adhere to the constitution
that's just what i observe you can let
me know if you agree with it i think
that's why it rubs people the wrong way
and you you see it as inauthentic when
democrats claim some kind of
constitutional argument or precedent uh
because of course biden went on to make
the argument that maga republicans what
what what don't respect the constitution
maga republicans do not respect the
constitution
they do not believe in the rule of law
the will of the people
they refuse to accept the results of a
free election
and they're working right now
as i speak in state after state
to give power
to decide elections in america to
partisans and cronies
powering election deniers to undermine
democracy itself
cronies would yeah
well we're talking about cronies we're
talking about you know sort of political
hatchet men we're talking about people
who are lifetime politicians would 50
years suckling at the public teeth
qualify joe yeah
and as recently as just a few years ago
your own party was saying hey we need to
shore up election security to make sure
that our elections can be trusted
because we're switching from you know
paper to technology and sometimes that
can be a little wonky
everybody that is making changes right
now there may be an outlier or two here
or there right and we'll get those
people out of the party because they're
not really conservatives in the first
place all of the changes that are being
made right now all of the processes that
are being looked at are to make it
harder to cheat yeah because we know
that it can and does happen let's even
take the most extremists right the most
actual like an actually a legitimately
small percentage people who think the
ghost of chavez came back and rigged
dominion voting machines okay
what is unconstitutional about someone
happened what is unconstitutional about
someone questioning that yeah there's
nothing in other words if they're saying
hey i don't believe this election was
legitimate if someone says that there's
nothing that would be incongruent with
the constitution right so my question to
you is which side actually cares about
the constitution they try and say you
don't care about the constitution
if you question election integrity
okay i don't see where in the
constitution it says you're not allowed
to question uh state laws that have been
changed for example that go against the
state constitution like in pennsylvania
i don't see anyone in the constitution
the two cannot be parallel my question
is can you be
in line with the constitution and the
framers intent if you don't believe that
the second amendment is absolute
oh yeah what about the first amendment
freedom of speech right what about what
about the freedom of of assembly right
not shutting down people in churches for
example you have in canada but here in
the united states with public gatherings
depending on political persuasion in
other words which side cares about the
constitution you cannot say hey we need
to disarm people and then claim but
we're pro-constitution because we don't
want you to question election integrity
hey we're pro-constitution but uh we
also think that there's a limit on uh on
the first amendment and freedom of
speech if it's too offensive they
they never are in line with the
constitution as a result of their
policies and their platform but they
want you to believe that you're
shredding the constitution if you say
i'm not sure
that mail-in ballots with no id is the
best way to conduct elections and not
being congruent with the constitution
would be telling that person they're not
you know they don't have the right to
have that opinion right or say that out
loud exactly what they're doing right
now right and he also said that
republicans don't respect the rule of
law wait a minute i'm sorry was it
republicans that took to the street and
started burning down cities for the
summer of love yes i don't think so i
don't think it's the republicans who go
out into the streets and start torching
towns when things don't go the way or
when massive events happen obviously
that was a big deal for everybody but we
we don't do that you're forgetting about
uh september 11th two hmm january 6th
there was poops yep
hey guys there was this keep it peaceful
they're gonna let us sit you mean that
january there were poops and there was a
little model noose yes and i do believe
they were possibly waved in
possibly i only judged that by the video
yeah it was just like we had the guys
with the uh the cones and the flags
waving the hijackers in a 911
right
no didn't happen that'd be weird walking
into work that day yeah who's that
feller yeah why is he up on scaffolding
with
tracker balloons so
then biden attempted to walk back his
comments and soften them but then double
down on them again he did this oh it
wasn't saturday it was it was sunday
it's hard because labor day so it messes
me up so here's biden walking his
comments back on sunday after that
speech i want to be very clear up front
not every republican is a migrant
republican republican embraces that
extreme ideology i know because i've
been able to work with mainstream
republicans my whole career
but the extreme micro republicans in
congress have chosen to go backwards
full of anger violence hate and division
but together we can and we must choose a
different path okay so hold on a second
i'm gonna get to the violence in a
second but this is what he this is the
divide and conquer right everything is
through seen through the the lens of
class of race of gender
sexual orientation the same thing here
he's trying to do it but with people on
the right
he's trying to give you an out to say oh
i'm not with them i'm not with the maga
people no no don't be fooled by it
because then he says unlike the
mainstream republicans who i've been
able to work with
that's complete unadulterated
monkey pox [ __ ] so
let's look at the inflation reduction
his biggest accomplishment right one of
the biggest bills if i believe it is the
biggest if not one of the biggest i
don't know if you adjust for inflation
ironically the inflation reduction act
zero republicans voted for it in the
house zero republicans voted for it in
the senate so are they all maga in other
words not the ones that i've worked with
so in other words
all of them because you've been unable
to work with any and by the way this
includes republican wieners who i don't
like and i think are weak
they wouldn't go with you so okay not
the republicans who i've worked with on
your biggest legislative accomplishments
name one
liz cheney no adam kensinger no not even
them
romney
not even mitt
ovalton
so he says that and he tries to walk it
back but i guess cnn didn't get the memo
because they had their skeleton crew
because
because they're all being fired they do
their little reality check thing which
is just oh
no but it's different it's this guy it's
uh avalon john abbott i hate him yeah
but he's not the one usually does the
reality check is it is it shooto i
forgot i don't know it's avalon is it
always everywhere yeah oh well screw
that guy frankie yeah no
no so john avalon then tried to defend
the initial attacks on maga republicans
that biden made before biden said that's
not what i meant so they need to sort of
they need to get together on the rule
book here from cnn running interference
for the most popular president of course
of all time but what we need most and
have least of right now is perspective
on our politics and that's why you're
going to give it to us a typically
thoughtful analysis from the washington
post
about trying to find exactly how many
americans a lot going on the criteria
extremist republicans now hear the
criteria they reject the 2020 election
results embraced candidates who also
reject the results approve of the
capital riot and finally
don't lump that all in as a political
tool now we've all seen polling about
how 60 to 70 of republicans believe
trump's election lies but here's the big
thing to remember
just 28 of americans identify as
republicans according to a recent gallup
survey so even if 66 percent of
republicans believe that biden's not a
legitimate president as july cnn poll
found that's just over 18 percent of all
american adults and what about the 41
million independent voters well even if
you add in the one-third of independents
who lean republican you're still talking
about a decidedly minority opinion i
love by the way how he thinks he has to
do all of this estimating like yeah you
don't need that math equation you can
just look at the polls and say hey how
many americans think that we need
tighter election security so it's more
than just 18 of americans just to be
clear it's like almost half of the
country thought there was foul play in
this last election depending on which
poll you use and depending on which week
but he's like if you take this percent
of a self-identified republican then it
could be this percentage and if you take
this independent so if we estimate we
don't need to do that
well i love that he said only 28 percent
of america's republicans and then under
it says demik democrat 20 29
and half of those voter rolls are dead
oh yeah i know it's amazing this is this
is the worst kind of because he said at
the end of that too he threw these
criteria out what are mega republicans
right you believe the lie you vote for
candidates that believe the lie you you
think january 6 was okay i think a lot
of republicans i don't think a lot of
republicans were saying hey everything
that happened on january 6 was just fine
i had a problem most of the people there
wouldn't agree with you with the
hundreds of thousands of people you're
talking about like two dozen who
actually went in the restaurant hey guys
i don't think you should do that hey
don't think and by the way fed fed fed
that thing yeah the last thing that he
put on there was so that every single
person would start shaking their heads
and go yeah he's right they believe in
violence as a political tool right where
was that in your poll john yeah what did
you ask people do you believe that ev is
violence never okay we wouldn't be a
country if that was the case right
because we had a little bit of violence
to kind of become a country kind of
basis in our country our government here
but you're starting to pit people
against each other because you have to
broaden these terms into things that
scare people that's it that's all john's
doing he's not giving you perspective
he's out there being a bite an apologist
and he's stumbling through his words
much like hair biden yeah i know he's
just so stupid by the way if it's only
18 of americans well biden can't just
run against 18 no of americans that's
the thing if that's all it is then this
is wrap it up this is an easy election
for joe biden that's not even the
percentage of his brain that worked
you mean 18 of the 10 percent yes 18 of
the time yeah
18 of the 10 which means it's i don't
know is that very little yes he's not a
man of my math
i don't want to diagnose him like that
[ __ ] from yale who diagnosed donald
trump and just lost her spot at yale did
you see that
it's got to be good they were like
why why did i lose because you're
supremely unqualified and you diagnosed
someone who you never saw as a patient
and you were wrong well i guess that
makes sense yeah i oh oh so i have to be
accurate yes you do oh unbelievable what
dark times so
he wants you to believe it's only 18
percent okay if only 18 of the country
are mega republicans and by the way maga
let's just be honest mean synonymous
with people who would vote for donald
trump yeah uh
then the election wouldn't be an issue
of course they don't believe that and
then he talks about that how they
support violence look we don't have to
guess and do a number and fractions and
the common denominator and do you know
do do cross uh was it cross cross
division trust division is that what it
is i have no idea so i had a math
teacher told me cross division was a
myth long division crossover no cross
multiplication crossbones would put me
in skirts and call it cross division i
don't know i have yesterday solves all
the problems right cross multiplication
i had a math teacher tell me it was a
myth and i was like but i come to the
same answer he's like yeah but you can't
actually do it it's not the right way to
do it it's like i don't care i'm just
getting angry at that story
you should just not at you which story
just the idea that your teacher said i
just don't understand that math stuff
yeah you get
past addition subtraction division i'm
like hey yeah calculator i have a
calculator yeah but this is uh
this is something i also want you to
believe is that you if you support for
example the idea of strengthening
election integrity in other words when
they say or they think that elections
aren't free and fair
let's let's be specific about that do
you believe in voter id you're a maga
extremist right
period
we've done segments on that of course
they paint anyone who believes in having
identification to vote
as being an extremist so here's another
question that i have uh if it's really
only that small of a percentage of
people who support the use of political
violence
let's let's assume that's true is it
right-wingers we're an actual threat to
democracy for talking about violence if
if we just distill it down to okay maybe
they believe the election
but violence right
we're talking about citizens extremist
citizens who are willing to be violent
that's kind of the last argument they
have
because none of the rest makes sense you
know this and i know this why did i say
this i should say that i sound like
arnold saying that you know this i know
this we both know this who says this
and you know this put that cookie down
man so
we know the the numbers of of of
the billions of dollars in damages and
i'll get to that well you know here let
me just cite these really quickly during
the riots of course there was what there
was
at least two billion dollars in
insurance claims this is collage d4
they're given uh six hundred thousand
officer casualties thirty deaths in the
summer of love right sixty thousand
officer casualties what did i say you
had a zero i said six hundred thousand
said six hundred sixty thousand sixty
thousand sixty thousand dollars i know
you're saying sixty sixty 000 officers
weren't killed no casualties these
includes include serious injury as well
so these were going on
at a time in the country right we were
streaming this live i remember when i
said mostly peaceful hey hold on a
second what was then uh presidential
nominee sorry vice presidential nominee
kamala harris what did she say back then
what were talking about extremists she
had she was watching the extremists
right billions of dollars in damages
tens of thousands of officer casualties
david david dorn and a police officer
shot dead over a tv set 30 officers shot
dead throughout that summer entire
square city blocks taken over by
anarchists
what was kamala harris saying at that
point in regards to political violence
and i want to make clear that i know
that there are protests still happening
in major cities across the united states
i'm just not seeing the reporting on it
that i that i had that's right and for
the first few weeks
um but they're not
they're not going to stop and that's
they're not
a movement i'm telling you they're not
so it gets worse and and everyone beware
because they're not gonna stop it is
gonna they're not gonna stop before
election day in november and they're not
gonna stop after election day and that
should be everyone should take note of
that on both levels that this isn't
they're not gonna let up and they should
not and we should not
[Music]
they should not there's a big difference
between saying they're not going to stop
like i said that i said they're not
going to stop
this is terrible but she says they're
not going to stop nor should they i
disagree with you respectfully
they should stop
it's all in tone yeah
she says it's smiling it's june when she
makes that comment they're not going to
stop up to election day november they're
not going to stop after
ah so you mean even if you win the
election that's not going to be enough
is that what you're saying it's never
enough until you completely change this
country and go away from the
constitution which we just talked about
right thank you for telling us exactly
what you're going to do if people would
only listen to that can't stop till you
get enough which by the way she also
listened to in 1962 don't know how she
did it with tupac yeah so uh here's
something worse with her tape records
she didn't just say they shouldn't stop
she raised money to bail out violent
rioters during the minnesota riots in
case you've forgotten she tweeted if
you're able to chip in now to the
minnesota freedom fund to help post bail
for those protesting on the ground in
minnesota now um
this isn't just
a lone
gunman no when you're talking about
these riots again put yourself back
where you were during these riots they
want to memory hole you i find myself
and i'm going wait a second
am i did i dream that they had lit a cop
car on fire did i dream that they tried
to ransack the cnn building and the
police oh did i did jazz chop not happen
were they right now or acting as a let
me ask you this
joe biden went up and gave this speech
okay political violence
what's the catalyst for it
in recent weeks what major act of
political violence from the mega crowd
the right crowd has happened
every single day
thousands were happening during those
riots throughout the summer yeah
what what's the catalyst for this in
other words there is none they don't
have anything so they're trying to warn
you about violence that may come and as
dave said there's a theory that maybe
they're trying to actually stir it up of
course don't take the bait from the fed
glowworms this this kamal hairs to the
back fund um just so you know it helped
release repeat felon shawn michael
tillman on april 29th he was uh charged
with murder august 30th so he was
released
who could have seen that coming that the
guy who wanted to defund the police and
burn down buildings yeah and a walgreens
might actually go on to continue being a
violent criminal yeah and this is the
fun that she told you to contribute to
if you have time to help out to get
these freedom fighters out of jail you
mean the murderer yeah you're saying a
violent criminal got out and hurt
somebody
is there something wrong with our prison
system well it's not wrong with her
prison system so much as it is her
twitter profile oh yeah because she got
him money to be bailed out oh right he
didn't make it to the prison system she
belongs to the streets it's more like a
revolving door like elf well of course
just keep going around you're just
confused in it and then they let you go
did were you about to say something
there jill no okay
did you have something you want to stay
on youtube or not
because there are things that i want to
say
no i don't know what's behind doors you
never know
yes yeah no trust me i wouldn't claim
that 98.5 percent of monkey pox cases
are between men that have sex with men i
would never do that i'm curious as to
what you have at the end of that hershey
we'll we'll do it all what's there
all right we'll talk about this one
we'll talk about this on mug club say
it's in the land of pure imagination
please yes yeah no that doesn't work and
if gerald wants to see paradise
simply look around and he will where am
i portland
anything you want to say it
the schnaazberry it tastes like monkey
pop
[Laughter]
the sores the sores are weeping i hope
it'll last
what's the monkey parks from gay butt
sex no no you can't have monkey pots no
you had gay butt sex and identify as
bisexual so you get nothing
those are oompa loompas they're that
color
cause
the monkey pox comes with comorbidities
like jaundice
giving it to you
[Laughter]
spreading it around is what we do
what do you get when your anus prolapses
uh we want to say on youtube
and now i'm not the cause of it
97.5 97 points plus one plus plus yeah
the bisexual don't forget the plus one
bisexual and there's a dog that's like i
love croc yes
only you can take a bite out of ass
here's my red rocket let's get it
i'm ready you ready
uh what was his name
well that was rough mcgraw those were
scruff mcrae the new guy is ruff mcruff
scrote mccock
id the monkey pots frog
your dog bit well he more licked me yeah
hey you know what i think courage did
you know what i think is extremist
allowing a gay sex festival to go on in
san francisco and then declaring a
statewide emergency for monkey pox the
very next day
i think that is more extreme than
pulling the lever for donald trump i
don't know and by the way how much
violence so
this is okay donald trump is the leader
of this uh maga movement that you say is
so dangerous and the rhetoric is so
violent how many uh how many protests
and cities have we had since you raided
for the first time in history raided a
president's
personal residence how many how many
protests how many cities have been
burned down how many officer casualties
have we had
i think the number on all of those
fronts is zero really the political
unrest the violence is really on this
side what more could you have done
to spark it it's a zero i think it's a
big zero what's a very small zero like a
balloon zero like a brown starfish
so i understand a lot of those documents
were just card tricks yes ah yes empty
folders
now if that were the case they would
have confiscated his hand because
it's always the ace it's always the uh
the the ace of the clubs
it's copper
could you imagine having him do a mat
like he would get so mad like ed look is
this your card no yes it is
this is a terrible match fake
all right now you can walk he just
pushes a kid out of a wheelchair
hey look at that
where's the one that's supposed to have
good legs
[Laughter]
all right uh speaking of we're talking
about violence a lot of you may believe
that violence can only be carried out
with guns right you'd be mistaken you
would be so my homeland of canada i
actually have one more question before i
get to this while we're talking about
monkey pox and gay stuff the bisexual
the one percent bisexual i have a theory
yeah totally a theory
if a guy says he if a woman says she's
bisexual particularly in college i mean
she's trying to be cool if a guy says
he's bisexual he's gay
comment below
does
does the defense hold water or monkey
pox i've never met a bisexual guy who
wasn't gay well yeah i just think that
the two guys one girl is uh
it's gay i even have the girl there yeah
i know it also seems like a lot of work
it's just somebody who's like yeah i was
there when i saw two men having sex i
just happened to be right middle yes
you basically had a finger trap right
just watching them like like queers in
the mist
can you come in because we're not fully
committed
i yet be late
[Laughter]
we'll start without you you're what we
call incidental yeah what does this
stelter put again yeah slumber party oh
you can wait outside and have some some
soda yeah because we're bisexual you
know yeah we got it correct like uh
we're the one percent bisexuals speaking
okay so let's while we're talking about
violence here canada the i say by
homeland i was born in detroit but i was
raised in canada okay it's a silly place
it's a stupid place and it has the worst
uh worst uh world leader i mean i use
that term loosely prime minister of
canada it's the worst leader of a
country i think on the planet right now
is trudeau i don't know that you can get
much worse
but sunday and this is incredibly sad
two men went uh and they wounded
eighteen killed ten
on a mass i know what you're you're
thinking the next word will be
mass stabbing spree
here's clip the knife attack is one of
the deadliest mass killings in canada's
history canadian police say the two
suspects damien sanderson and miles
sanderson are on the run after stabbing
multiple people and they're armed and
dangerous we are confident that someone
out there knows the whereabouts of these
two and has information that would be
valuable to the police authorities say
the first shouldn't you take place at
about 5 40 a.m on sunday push this news
clip they were notified of the others
across the james smith cree nation
police say there are at least 13
different crime scenes and by the way
that is from the original news it's like
it's like revolution number nine just
going to one header
yeah they split the audio so um trudeau
also tweeted out uh the attacks in
saskatchewan today are horrific and
heartbreaking i'm thinking of those who
have lost a loved one and of those who
were injured now
keep in mind
this is one thing a macro point here a
lot of people say well the reason we
need to ban assault weapons and by the
way assault weapon assault weapon right
i'm carrying all of us in here have your
have your assault weapons if it's over
10 rounds
depending on the aesthetics in other
words it's an undefined term
when people say well you can't do as
much damage with a shotgun you can't do
as much damage with a revolver you can't
do as much damage with a bolt action you
can't do as much damage with a knife
here's the thing a lot it's it's a mind
warp
and you're you even a conservative
american out there who tends to be
informed and often we can see that you
check our references
may not realize that you're still sort
of keeping
your inherent bias in place that you're
thinking about well yeah i guess they
would do less damage with a knife in the
united states
because they'll be stopped by someone
with a gun but in a place like canada or
you see this in france you see it all
across europe on a regular basis if
there isn't a good guy with a gun
you can kill just as many people with a
knife
of course you can go on a mass stabbing
spree who's going to stop them
in a land where people are disarmed
all that is required for someone to do
massive damage is a willingness
to break the unwritten rules and i know
we have written rules crime laws i'm
saying it's an unwritten agreement if
you're in a room with people that you
don't stab me right i'm sort of banking
on you not stabbing me the united states
the unwritten agreement we also have is
i'm hoping you don't stab me and you
don't know what i have on my belt
i don't trust you right but if you're
healthy if you take into account no no
in the united states you don't think a
mass stabbing can happen
right it can happen where people don't
have guns right it's very very easy for
tab and it's actually not even
altogether uncommon and trudeau
obviously previously stated that uh
we've run this clip before canadians and
he thought this was a good thing but do
not have the right to use guns for
self-protection
[Applause]
sorry wrong clip or right clip here's
the clip that i was looking for
you can't use a gun for self protection
in canada that's not a right that you
have in the constitution or anywhere
else if you try and buy a gun and say
it's for self-protection no you don't
get that
there are at least 10 people and 18
others that would disagree with you
right now justin they would love the
right to be able to use a gun for
self-protection yeah and i know what
they're saying is yeah but that guy who
stabbed them could have used a gun as
well sure but here's the thing i believe
that a more evil act
is to rob someone of their right to
self-defense i believe that is more evil
than allowing everyone to own a firearm
and understanding that violence is a
part of the human condition
it is unconscionable evil to me
to force citizens to be sitting ducks
that is very very different from people
accepting the risk of living in a
society where people are allowed to
protect themselves one is proactively
stripping law-abiding citizens of their
basic god-given human rights and the
other is unfortunately a part of the
human condition which will never go away
that some of us are violent peace is a
two-way street
if one person doesn't want it guess what
you don't have it period you don't have
it that's it i want peace i don't now we
have a decision to make and by the way
monday morning
the suspects were still at large one of
them now thank god killed himself but
this is from the police department
unfortunately the two males are still as
large as leukemia despite
ongoing relentless efforts through the
night by both the rcmp and the regina
police service to locate these two
individuals they have not yet been
located and so efforts continue we've
got a fresh set of investigators and
shifts coming in today uh that will take
over this investigation and we will not
stop this investigation until we have
those two safely in custody
but why safely how about unsafely in
custody if he just got stabbed
yeah in whatever condition we happen to
bring them in yeah in custody i don't
care if you bring them back in pieces
put their head on a turtle
safely back in custody these were
violent criminals need to be brought
back without a scratch yeah they'll get
a stern talking to you trust me yeah on
that i will waggle my finger at them
well here's the thing too a lot of
people don't we have a lot of shootings
we've had plenty of shootings actually
in canada so montreal three we had uh
concordia polytechnic and i had friends
at dawson college when people were shot
uh mass shootings right these had taken
place and one of them was uh
technic was one of the first mass
shootings he lined up women against the
wall and shot them in the back they had
execution style
yeah because he was he thought he was
being fired for being a man and it was
like an affirmative action a quota with
hiring guy just completely went off the
rails and
again he can do that because no one can
defend themselves right no one is
executed
by a citizen unless they are disarmed
right that's very different but here's
the thing we've had plenty of mass
shootings you do have mass shootings in
the united states you have mass
shootings across the world and sure the
united states is toward the top of that
list as far as mass shootings not
violent crime
not homicide not even necessarily just
gun crime
and they still aren't even number one as
far as mastering the point is mass
shootings exist everywhere something
that you don't see in the united states
however you see this mass stabbing right
10 victims 10 people dead i believe with
18 people stabbed
it reminded me of what happened in nova
scotia uh years ago uh where there was a
a guy a 51 year old
gabriel wartman
was this in 2020 was that recently
really okay i thought it was longer ago
oh yeah the last few years have just
flown by he killed 22 people
at 16 locations wow just like the mass
stabbing what happens they go from place
to place to place and they can't be
stopped you don't see that in the united
states you travel over a hundred
kilometers
because the article did come and i
didn't feel like doing the math of the
two points 60 something yeah about 60
something miles
um
that
is an evil that is very hard to grasp
and it's also really hard to grasp a
government that has created a scenario
where someone can go knock on doors like
he was trick-or-treating and kill 22
people you know why no one could stop
him
this went on for days yeah he's just
walking around traveling shooting people
just like right now they haven't caught
these two stabbers one of them committed
suicide
yeah well we had the sunderland springs
example where somebody did stop him he's
on his way to do something else
somewhere else an nra certified
instructor stephen wilford this was the
first show he did would have it was one
of the most deadly mass shootings in
history before vegas i think it actually
was certainly top two yeah was that the
one in texas yeah yeah i met uh
two kids whose parents were killed in
that yeah well we had the guy who killed
the shooter yeah he's on the show steven
williford is the most one of the most
awkward things i've had to do because he
wanted to come on this show because he's
a fan of the show and i didn't want to
be exploitative so i said look whatever
you want to talk about and when he
started crying on air i didn't want to
be barbara walters thing so i just
wanted to be honest with him and say
look you this term is thrown on
flippantly you are a hero this guy was
gonna
this guy this shooter in sutherland
springs was planning on going to another
church yeah
just shooting shooting shooting and the
good guy with a gun stopped him and by
the way there are millions of examples
every year of a good guy with a gun in
canada you have a mass stabbing because
no one can do anything and then you have
this guy who killed 22 people at 16
separate locations in addition to mass
shootings like you have here in the
united states again i ask you
do you believe that you will stop human
nature if you don't if you believe that
some human beings will inherently and
flagrantly disregard the law in order to
harm their fellow citizens then you
understand why the second amendment is a
god-given right even if you're one of
those edgy atheists who doesn't like to
believe in god thank god the racist
founding fathers did because they said
it's a right that government doesn't
grant and they can't take away
government only serves to protect your
god-given rights that's what inalienable
means means it's not granted by the
government and by the way this shooter
nova scotia uh
for people who don't remember this we
talked about it when it happened he had
apparently been publicly embarrassed by
his final victim
uh gina goulet at a work conference a
lady recounted who worked with them she
said gina responded to something gabriel
had said with oh for f sake gabe you
don't know that or something like that
my eyes went big and like
i knew that gina had embarrassed him and
he knew it because he and i made eye
contact gina then said
so what it's effing gabe what's he going
to do
um
well i guess ask the police report
yeah he's he's going to go on a 100
kilometer killing spring and kill you
last yeah are you serious yeah that's
what she said she said what's he gonna
do that was the last victim
where he said remember me she was like
[ __ ]
all right ah gabe i guess you get the i
guess that's one for you gabe well
a dozen yeah call me once for me once
for me 22 times um and by the way saying
it's effing gabe is not going to help
yeah i know 7k what's he going to do i
don't know have you seen his browser
history
you just said effing gabe nah yeah yeah
i think he set him off no one could stop
him no imagine that just picture you
can't even fathom this in the united
states it's really hard if you think
wait the person just went through the
neighborhood no one stopped because even
if you're one of those [ __ ] who
doesn't have a gun or you don't want one
in the house
you know that someone else in your
neighborhood does yeah you know that
someone is going to put a stop to it not
in canada this is not the first time
this has happened it's happened with
guns it's happened with knives and this
happens across the world on a regular
basis and of course this will tie into
what what is happening with the midterms
if you look at joe biden saying we don't
want to take guns away we will actually
want to encourage a law-abiding citizens
to own guns and then goes on to say we
want to ban assault weapons which by the
way is almost all of your handguns just
to be clear
and by the way just to to touch up on
this we have an old video the united
states does not have the highest violent
crime in the world if you look at the
murder rates per 100 thousand you have
el salvador you have jamaica you have
honduras uh we have less than five
homicides per 100 thousand jamaica for
example has 43 el salvador has 52. and
we're not even in the top 10 for mass
shootings in the western world just to
be clear we're ranked 11th
now i'm not saying that we don't have a
substantial amount of gun violence here
in the united states of course we do and
any gun violence is is too much i don't
mean that in a way to strip you of your
firearm rights i mean it's sad because
human beings committing violence against
each other is a it's a sad prospect
but when you take into account it's 14
000 when you're talking about gun
homicides per year anywhere from 12 to
20 tops and most of it is intergang
related because i'm not including the
suicide statistics yeah but guess what
you know that's
it's unfortunate it's tragic every
single life lost but it's not the same
as people being
completely defenseless sitting ducks for
days on end
relying on the help from your mounties
right or your government right so joe
biden's making the case that violent
maga extremists
people out there we're trying to take
away all the guns in society but he's
talking to a crowd of people who pretty
much typically don't own firearms right
right most democrats who's going to save
them
not them
not not their neighbors they have to
trust in government they have to trust
in the elite and combined too when you
have kamala here's the lady who was
saying like they're not going to stop
they're going to continue and nor should
they they shouldn't continue that's not
a bad kamala no should they they should
continue
that's
the last part
she's saying that and this is the same
person saying they should continue
meaning burning looting killing cops
and you shouldn't have the right to own
firearms yeah combine that
that's evil yeah that's evil even if you
believe that there's an equivalent from
donald trump or from republic which
there isn't
a call to action to violence
if you believe that me for example
saying this tomorrow is war and i come
on the show and say i'm not calling you
to violence but if you believe that that
is just as extreme at the very least
i'm not trying to disarm you
someone calling half the population to
violence
while attempting to disarm the other
half
i i i i
that not everybody sees it that is so
much more sinister when they say donald
trump is a fa well generally fascists
don't want a population as armed as
humanly possible
they don't want a small government they
don't want to give you more freedom and
flexibility and more of your own money
to be able to spend fascism has
apparently changed into something
completely new but if you're
joe biden right now and you're democrats
and you believe that there is this
threat that is out there that is just
waiting for an event to go off wouldn't
you want your side to be armed if you're
like that's the inevitable end they're
going to come after us with guns and try
to take over our country wouldn't you
want every opportunity to defend
yourself would you want every one of
your citizens to be armed right they
don't they want they want because here's
the thing for the same reason violence
is amoral
people don't like hearing this violence
and sex for example they are amoral acts
you'll see a lot of europeans say you
americans are so uh you're so hung up
about sex and you're advertising but
you'll allow violence on a second if you
maybe like violent action films which
you do as well europe can you can you
name a dutch action star no of course
not they're the most jealous people in
the world everyone in europe right uh
sean van klogg yes john van klogg he
wears his wooden shoes logenstein this
is the thing is they have our stars our
biggest export is culture and we don't
have their stars no uh same thing sweden
finland they look down at the united
states and they say by the way you know
how we didn't want a nato uh we were
wrong about that can we can we come in
no you i don't know you owe about 700
billion dollars then we'll
to stop the rape of a woman
sex can be something beautiful in a
monogamous loving relationship ideally
marriage
or it can be gross and one night stan or
lead to monkey pox the point is the
context really matters we don't put
breasts and naked women on our
advertising billboards like they do in
quebec like they do in europe because we
don't think it's age-appropriate for the
same reason we have a film rating system
and kids are not allowed to watch
r-rated films so they think that america
is hung up on violence but here's the
thing
in a society where you strip people of
their right to own firearms and for the
same reason that violence is amoral and
for the same reason that a gun is the
only thing that can make a woman as
strong as a man there's nothing else
that can make a woman as strong as a man
outside of a gun it's now a mechanical
advantage as opposed to a physical one
the law-abiding citizens if not allowed
to defend themselves will be the victims
of violence period
because lawless people will always
commit violence they do not care so when
you strip the citizenry of firearms you
disproportionately affect
women
law-abiding citizens the disabled
because it's the only thing that evens a
playing field so to answer your question
this is a long way around but they don't
want their citizens to be able or their
voters their constituents to be able to
defend themselves
they want their voters to be
violent offensively and then be
subjugated
that's what they want because guess what
if they have knives if you ban the
citizens from owning firearms well guess
what these people who are rioting and
alluding and four billion dollars in
damages and sixty thousand officer
casualties they're gonna find a way
to violently assault the citizens once
that's taken place well now these people
though they don't have the kinds of
weapons where we can't subjugate them
their goal is control over
all of you
from taxes
down to what you can say
down to what kind of a grip your firearm
can have again if we're talking about
fascism
let's say you believe donald trump's a
fascist fine
he's a really bad one concer american
conservatism is a really bad platform
for fascism real how are you going to
control your population we're going to
control them by uh lowering taxes by
allowing them to say whatever they want
uh you know because we believe the first
amendment is that i want giant buildings
that prove i'm a capitalist right
and allow them to own firearms so that
uh you know they can fight off a
cannibal government i think this is good
for a yeah that seems you could probably
do some kind of a venn diagram and that
would line up with pinochet or pol pot
all right i want to hear what you had to
say that we couldn't say on youtube
please hit the like button share if you
can uh again this is parody week so
tomorrow we have another song you can go
listen to my spotify apple android you
can actually download the songs dave is
going to be in port shore at port
charlotte port charlotte tell them where
you're going to be this weekend friday
and saturday vassani's in port charlotte
florida and then next week we are in
houston oh that's right phoenix and
houston that's right well phoenix is
sold out yeah yeah yeah yeah there are
still seats in youtube because we
expanded it so houston september 17th
and send your emails to tips at lottery
credit.com we will fly 50 lucky west
virginians out you youtube thank you
very much i really want to hear what
gerald had to say hopefully do you still
have it in your memory bank i'll i'll
get it back oh well okay youtube piss
off